Brian's previous may have one of the
hardest jobs in America as chairman of
the RNC he's in charge of uniting the
party behind this presumptive
presidential nominee Donald Trump and
this is the cover story the latest
Bloomberg Businessweek author Josh green
joins us now so you were telling us
earlier that he's kind of like a foil to
Donald Trump the presumptive nominee you
know if you were a reality TV show
producer and you were casting somebody
to be kind of the straight man foil to
Donald Trump it would be rights Priebus
who is a sweet quiet gentle man who
wants to do good things in the world and
everything that he's worked to build
over the last five years Trump has kind
of come through like a wrecking ball and
probably set back his his efforts to
kind of moderate and broaden the appeal
at a Republican Party so the cover I
Bloomberg Businessweek where he's kind
of sitting in his desk with his head in
his hands I mean is that an accurate
description of your interview in your
conversation with him I believe that it
is yes I had long interviews in the
piece with both Priebus and Donald Trump
and what I really kind of grapple with
is that each of them has their own
vision of where they think the
Republican Party should go previous
mission for five years after romney's
loss was to moderate the image of the
party to work really hard to try and
attract non-white voters Millennials
women whereas Trump has this kind of
nativist populist brand that smashes
political correctness and could do great
damage to the future of the Republican
Party if he doesn't get elected I know
you said he was this sweet man but he
seemed to rather tense at different
points when you were interviewing we did
flip out at me in the interview but but
really the tension here and this is what
i get at and the piece is you know i
asked him again and again you know you
have a candidate who both insists Barack
Obama wasn't born in the United States
has called Hispanics rapists and drug
dealers how can you possibly hope to
attract Hispanics and young people and
women and moderates how can you broaden
the party's appeal with Trump at the top
of the ticket and that was a question he
had a difficult time answering she said
you asked a few times I mean what was
the general take away from that answer
the general take away from that answer
was they didn't like the question right
so much but his his his deputy kind of
jumped in and blew a whistle on the
interview so we went off the record for
a little bit but previous does insist
you know they've been working very hard
for years he'd been
minority communities he told me he
thinks Trump will perform better with
Hispanic and black voters the mitt
romney did not a prediction i myself
would make but we'll see all right well
he is a spokesman for the party you also
took readers inside the private meeting
between Donald Trump and Paul Ryan what
did you learn there well the big issue
in Republican politics right now is can
Donald Trump unite the party and the
most prominent holdout has been House
Speaker Paul Ryan who does not believe
that Trump is a conservative and thinks
that he's going to do great damage to
the conservative movement they had a
famous summit in Washington on May
twelfth nobody leaked nobody talked I
have a source who was inside the room
and describes to our readers Trump
dressing down Ryan for foolishly trying
to cut entitlements while Democrats are
offering more and essentially saying you
know I'm Donald Trump I'm going to put
my stamp on the party your crowd has
lost the Republican Party is now what I
say it is